if you're if you're looking at face
value I can understand why you would be
judged from your past but if if I'm a
guy interested in you I don't care about
what you've done
like men do though that's the thing like
like a virgin's more valuable to a man
than a girl that's had sex with multiple
men like it just is what it is there's a
limit but the modern man see which is
not a virgin a modern man is a partner
somebody that is actually simply smart
and could surviving the world
the man with the most Choice they're
gonna pick women that are more pure in
general the ones already self-made I
guess so but that's the thing the
reality is the reality is that there's a
lot of men out there especially in the
world that we live in today that need a
partner so it's time for those masses of
men to start respecting women for the
role they can play in their lives I
don't think I don't think average men
expect women
[Music]